وفتنة في الفريق القانوني
للرئيس أه محامي الرئيس رودي
جولياني وجينا إليس
أصدروا بيانًا الليلة الماضية
أعلنوا فيه أن سيدني باول محامية
مثيرة للجدل
كانت جزءًا من هذا الفريق القانوني
تشير إلى أنها لم تكن أبدًا سيدني
باول لأن الممارس
يمارس القانون  هي ليست
عضوًا في الفريق القانوني
الرابح ، كما قال رودي جولياني وجينا إليس في
بيان الليلة الماضية ،
لكن قبل أيام قليلة فقط يوم الخميس الماضي
رأينا سيدني
باول جنبًا إلى جنب مع رودي جولياني وجينا
إليس في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي في
مقر اللجنة الوطنية الجمهورية
، وبالتالي فإن السؤال هو بالضبط ما الذي
دفعها إلى طردها ، ونحن نعلم أن سيدني باول
كانت تتاجر
في مجموعة من نظريات المؤامرة حول
هذه الانتخابات
، وقد زعمت أن مزيجًا من
وكالة المخابرات المركزية الأمريكية الزعيم الفنزويلي الراحل
هوغو شافيز وربما حتى
الحاكم الجمهوري لجورجيا كان
متورطا في تزوير هذه الانتخابات
بالطبع تلك النظريات المؤامرة
أساس الصفر في الواقع أو الواقع ولكن
المفارقة جون أنهم ليسوا كل هذا
بعيد المنال
مما سمعناه من
الرئيس نفسه ومن رودي جولياني
الذي زعم أيضًا أن هناك بعض
نظرية المؤامرة
لتزوير الانتخابات لحذف الأصوات أه
بطريقة سحرية من الرئيسة
وسيدني باول ، أما من جانبها ، فهي
تقول إنها ستستمر في استكشاف
هذا الأمر ، وتقول إنها
ستستمر في تمثيلنا
نحن الشعب